what's hard for me to wrap my head
around is it's such a daunting task to
make a movie but then you're getting
you're doing all these things Guardians
one is a huge success Guardians 2 is a
huge success Suicide Squad Peacemaker
and then someone's over at DC says hey
we want you to run the studio yeah what
would make someone first of all did you
think about saying no that's not what I
want to do and almost say no when it
first came up I was like
but what eventually became appealing to
me was doing it with Peter so Peter
Safran when it came to us as us as a
pair and basically Peter sort of
managing everything working as a
producer and me basically working as a
director directing the creative aspects
of things that became a different story
that became suddenly an opportunity to
do something that had never been done
before you know film television gaming
and more
um and to to Really create a cohesive
you know DC Universe